triangles congruent I'm gonna show you a
process that I use and I help students
kind of work through so they don't get
stuck when they're doing these two
column proofs the first thing I like to
do is kind of just look through the
problem and kind of see what I can
figure out from the Givens first then
from the diagram a second then if I have
two from previous steps you know you can
figure out some additional quantities
that are congruent so the first thing I
do is take the Givens I say okay line Ln
bisects angle ml oh and angle MN oh okay
so let's look at that so here's line Ln
it's bisecting angle M L oh so that it
means it's cutting it in half by means
two sec means cut so it means that these
two angles are congruent so I like to
mark it on the diagram and then when I
figure things out I also like to make it
a step in my proof so I'm gonna go ahead
and put that down let's see it's angle
ml oh whoops angle angle M L o is
congruent to angle o ln o ln and also
because it says that it's bisecting this
angle as well angle MN oh we know that
this angle is congruent to this angle so
I'm going to combine that with step
number two here this is going to be
angle M and of all is congruent to angle
oh and now okay and say say they're
right m and l sorry angle M and L is
congruent to onl and the reason is
definition of angle bisector I'm just
abbreviating now notice I skipped step
number one step number one generally
what students like to do and I like to
do this too is just to put your Givens
first so I'm just gonna write for step
number one given and I'm just gonna draw
a line here okay but you would put those
Givens first now sometimes students like
to put it you know as they need those
particular Givens later on in the proof
so that it flows a little bit better but
most students when they're first
starting off they like to just get the
Givens out of the way by writing them
first whatever you're trying to prove
that's going to be your last statement
we're just trying to fill in the
in-between statements okay now it looks
like we've figured out everything that
we can from the Givens now I like to go
to the diagram I like to say well is
there anything that I can show is
congruent between these two try
from the diagram well it looks like
they're sharing this side these two
triangles have side L and in common so
I'm going to say for step number three
Pal n is congruent to L N and the reason
for that is the reflexive property so
it's just like looking in a mirror with
the same height in the mirror as you are
in real life meaning that a line is
gonna be the same in both triangles so
it's gonna be congruent to itself now
you can see that these two triangles are
congruent by angle-side-angle the sight
is in between the two angles that's what
they call the included side so that's
gonna be our last step what we're trying
to prove so triangle LM n is congruent
to triangle L o N and again you want to
make sure that the corresponding
vertices and the corresponding you know
angles of corresponding sides et cetera
the ones that are congruent to each
other gonna match up you know the order
is important so it looks like L M and
it's congruent to L o n you can see if
you fold that triangle those
corresponding vertices are gonna match
up and again that's going to be by the
angle side angle triangle congruence
theorem so great job if you want to see
some more examples proving triangles
congruent or just more examples with two
column proofs check out the playlist I
have right there for more practice with
those and if you're new to the channel
consider subscribing I have hundreds of
videos now on my channel helping you
with all different aspects of math to
make learning math a lot less stressful
and to help you pass your class boost
your score and go on to pursue whatever
it is that you're studying so great job
I'll see you in the next video